Peggy 18
hi my name is Paul Blasi and I am the
lead PC engineer on watchdogs during the
last years of development we have worked
closely with NVIDIA in order to create
the most vivid and breathtaking Chicago
possible for the PC version of watchdogs
one of the technologies that allowed us
to achieve this level of quality is an
Nvidia technique called HB ao+
which stands for horizon based ambient
occlusion
HPL plus improves upon existing yield
techniques to add richer more detailed
and realistic shadows around objects
that include razor blade HBO Plus is
faster more efficient and significantly
better compared to previous technique
to address smaller details and increase
the visual quality of watchdog we also
used Nvidia's TxAA technology TxAA is a
new cinematic style and here listen
technique designed specifically to
reduce temporal aliasing like crawling
and flickering that you may sometimes
see in motion when playing a game while
there is movement on the screen TxAA
will reduce the visual noise of
flickering across game elements like
fences cables grass or trees
these exclusive technologies are one of
the many tools that allowed us to create
an immersive and beautiful version of
watch stars
by working with nvidia we really want to
make sure pc gamers will be able to
enjoy and explore the most realistic and
visually stunning world environment ever
created the Windy City like you've never
seen it before we hope you enjoyed this
video see you in Chicago on May 27